no way they're going somewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what the deme Gorgon has happened to the
cast of stranger things in season 3
they've changed so much since the first
season but there's one character who has
literally become unrecognizable watch
until the end to find out just who we're
talking about Steve Harrington ok we'll
admit it
we totally hated Steve Harrington in the
first season he was a self-centered jerk
who made our Nancy cry yes of course is
the best hair on television since Berra
Fawcett but that's not the point
this guy was a total dirtbag at the
beginning of season 1 that's what makes
his transformation so compelling
he went from heart breaker to heart drop
for our very eyes his change began
toward the end of season 1 when he
joined forces with Nancy to fight the
deme gourd and he just kept getting
sweeter and sweeter after that in season
2 Steve took on more of a big brother
role of Dustin Henderson oh yeah I asked
he'll do he gave everything he had to
save will buyers from the terrorists the
mind player and he even used himself as
bait to leave the deme Gorgons out of
hiding now in season 3 it looks like
he's got some growing up to do
he still engages an imaginary sword
fights with Dustin all while wearing
that adorable sailor hat over his
perfectly coiffed hair after watching
the trailer we're not sure Steve's gonna
make it through all of season 3 but
because of his transformation from
rotten a sweet we're hoping he survives
Nancy wheeler in season one Nancy
started out the way all girls start out
in horror movies
she was the typical character who gets
corrupted by a bad boy and makes
terrible choices he just wants to get in
your pants
her friend who was the only one with
common sense tried to warn her sadly we
know where that got her hashtags justice
for barb usually the corrupted ones are
the first to go in a horror flick but
the Dufferin brothers turn this trope
upside down Barbara's the one who met
her unfortunate demise thanks to the
Demi Gorgon meanwhile Nancy was safer
with her bad choices upstairs what it
was Barb's disappearance that turned an
ant into a fighter in fact you might say
that Nancy was the pioneer for the
justice for barb campaign she went on a
revenge ran
Paige to make sure that Demi Gorgon paid
for what he did to her bestie and by the
end of season 2 Nancy was a gun-toting
Demi Gorgon punishing warrior we don't
know much about Nancy's role in season 3
but we can't wait to see what she does
next Jim hopper Jim hopper started the
series as a down-on-his-luck depressed
apathetic cop who lost his daughter and
subsequently his sense of purpose one at
a damn time however his sense of purpose
was restored when he got involved in
solving the mystery of wills
disappearance he went from being
childless and hopeless in the first
season to becoming the town hero what a
great friend to wills mom Joyce and the
adopted father of 11 in season two in
fact he seems to be the only one who can
win in a power struggle with this
spirited mighty girl from what we've
seen in the season 3 trailer hoppers job
is far from over after looking at those
rats and that scary monster in the
trailer
let's hope hoppers been training since
the last season because he's gonna need
all of his strength to beat that thing
will buyers poor poor will has not had
an easy go since the beginning of the
series she's been captured and brought
to the upside down
he got rescued only to have his body
taken over by the mind flayer he's been
tormented and tortured for two seasons
but with all those terrible
circumstances he still managed to evolve
into a more empowered character he
learned how to stand up for himself
against that giant enormous creature in
season 2 and even after all those
traumatic events he had to endure he
still went to the school dance he didn't
let it stop him from slow dancing with a
girl sure she called him zombie boy but
she's way cuter than the demi Corgan
lucas sinclair in season 1 lucas was the
voice of reason in the game take your
puny hole and multiply by 5 he was
naturally skeptical of 11 and all the
strange things that were happening in
Hawkins he was also the one who insisted
that the boys keep their pawns strong in
season 2 he settled into more of a
leadership role and he also met max your
cool and different
even worked up the courage to ask her to
dance he's come a long way from being
that dude who started out completely
skeptical of girls and outsiders Mike
wheeler Mike was the original leader of
the group he was the first to stand up
to injustice or to grab his trusty
walkie-talkie to lead his friends on a
quest to find will he took care of
eleven in the sweetest way in season one
maybe we didn't call you el 411 when he
thought he lost 11 at the end of the
first season he changed he had a lot
darker and more broody thankfully his
friends stepped in to help him through
that hard period by the end of season
two he had his groove back
he was feeling confident enough to dance
with 11 at the snowball we're not sure
if he'll be in the leaders seat for
season 3 but with his friends by his
side we're sure he can handle anything
that's on the horizon 1111 started out
as a scared little egg a loving girl who
was being manipulated by a man she
called papa
she escaped from the lab and became
friends with Mike yeah friends that
friendship changed everything for her
she went from being a timid reclusive
child to a confident strong formidable
hero with incredible control over her
powers 11 saved the day at the end of
the first season and then she went on to
become hoppers adopted daughter and yes
she went through a punky rebellious
phase as many teenagers do but she went
back to her pseudo family at the end of
season two we've seen 11 take her powers
to the max the end of season 2 and from
the season 3 trailer we know that you
can use your powers to play a good
surprise party prank on Dustin by making
his toys movie and we see her going to
the mall and listening to music like a
normal teenage kid but how will her
power stack up against the scary
monsters and stranger things 3 and which
will be hard to forever come the upside
down or the adolescent years tell us
what you think in the comments and be
sure to tell us who your favorite
character is while you're at it give
this video a big thumbs up if you love
stranger things and subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one
thanks for watching we'll catch you
later
[Music]